30-year-old right-hander julio tehran
who's making his tigers debut on the
mound today he's been around a while 10
years
in the big leagues he's faced cleveland
just one other time jonathan scope is
playing first base today this is his
first major league start at first base
then gamma left the plate
went too far in a strikeout to start the
day for julio tehran
two away for jose ramirez another 02.
kind of tap her back to him
you like that debut place for the first
inning i do nine pitches for julio
tehran to zach please sack to go out
there and do his thing making his first
start this year tigers have a man on and
now the payoff
drilled to left center will that get
down
it will
and bounce off the wall candelario's
being waved home castro's digging for
third he's got an rbi triple and the
tigers are on the board first and that's
why we're so encouraged with willie
castro the good hitters
hit the mistake pitches this is a
fastball it's up at the upper part of
the zone out over the middle of the
plate and he just puts a pounding on it
infield squeezing in against miguel
cabrera the o2
on the ground
nice play
he gets the job done castro was on the
move as soon as was hit
and the tigers now up their lead to two
rosario the cleanup hitter and left
almost wants that sinking fastball
and it's hammered and it is way out of
here and the indians get on the board
eddie rosario's first home run in a
cleveland uniform a no doubt about it
rope to the seats in right field not so
sure it was a sinker but it did tail
into his back the barrel ahead of his
bat it looked like it might have been
could have been a back up breaking ball
but i mean right into the barrel from
reyes is certainly one of the threats
the one two
not that time though
tehran
strikes him out for the first out in the
second no mar masara will lead off for
detroit here bottom of the second 2-1
tigers lead it
there's a fastball painted
and that is his first strikeout one down
yeah i sort of like that sequence good
low heater strike one and then he threw
a change up a breaking ball and comes
right back with a very good heater nico
good from batting left-handed
threw it by him good fastball had some
run to it
second strikeout for police act two down
and gamble at the plate
ben gamble struck out to start the day
on there backhand stab by scope to
second for one and the relay is in time
beautifully executed and for a guy who
has never played first base before an
absolute natural play for jonathan scope
here's fran mill reyes
sharply hit on the ground candelario a
nice play and a chance to turn two dug
out of the dirt by scope
well there's a test right there for
scope at first base can he pick it in
the dirt perez he saw eight pitches
before hitting his solid line single
into center his last time up puts him
away
and he comes back with that slider
locates it perfect
that was a good sequence right there by
tron
two away man on for cesar hernandez
and make that hitter stand still that
was a good poster to left and robbie
grossman is there
tehran needed that two ounces leads it
up to jamer candelario
and candy again just continues to hit
but i'm liking what i'm seeing from the
young fellas at the top of this batting
order on base for the second time jamer
candelario with a two out single here in
the fifth uh slider from police that
just stays right over the heart of the
plate and beautiful swing right there so
a two out single will give castro an
opportunity now
with two strikes though he wants that
curve ball to be a go fish pitch he's
out of it that a boy eddie rosario makes
the grab we've played five in motown 2-1
tigers first time we get a chance to see
derrick holland in a major league game
in a tiger's uniform
two away here's josh naylor have to
start that way again on the backhand
scope will take it himself and a nice
debut for derek holland here in 2021 to
keep it right where it is schliesek he's
done a nice job navigating here into the
sixth inning
the 2-1 sharply hit dan threw for a base
hit a couple of knocks for nomar mazzara
today
wilson ramos at the plate
there it is
on cue my friend rips it to left
back to back two out singles for the
tigers here in the sixth nikko goodrum
he's got a little pop
threw it by him good fastball ends the
inning four strikeouts for zach please
sack new role from michael fulmer this
year coming out of the bullpen
perez with a single and a strikeout the
3-1
territory stay in here scope giving
chase
got it
he did
took it right out of the cleveland
dugout for the second out but he keeps
focused on the baseball says hello to a
couple of his friends hello
two-way
nick whitford coming out to fish the
seventh sets the stage for jamer
candelario
the other way and that's a base hit
that's just beautiful jones is going to
score
grossman motors to third
it's an rbi double from jamer candelario
to extend the tigers lead 3-1 puts the
barrel to it japail easy decision to
send jacoby jones and robbie grossman
over to third so base is loaded for
jonathan scope
poke to right for naylor drifting over
grossman tags
the throw on its way it's cut off it's a
sacrifice fly for jonathan scope and the
tigers lead it 4-1
nomar mazzara steps to the plate another
3-2
offering to center field looping and
dropping
mazara with his third hit of the day and
his first rbi and great base running
right there eddie rosario air mails a
ball all the way to the catcher mazzaro
sees that he's he's going to go back to
first base but he sees once that ball's
in the air i can make it to second and
he scattles on down there so it's just
heads up base running too tyler
alexander takes over on the mound
back-to-back hits for the indians that's
going to give eddie rosario a chance
[Music]
high fly ball center field jones
will make the catch tagging and coming
home to score is cesar hernandez
and it's now five to two
stephen is ready here it comes
smashed
right field long run and a great catch
made by josh naylor just inside the line
for out number two
a little tougher play for the
left-hander he's got to go to his
backhand side but he catches it in fair
territory i believe it looked like it
was a fair ball three infielders shift
to the right castro joining goodram in
scope alone infielder on the left side
is candelario the outfield plays his
lefty go the opposite way
the 1-1 lifted to left robbie grossman
is there and the tigers start the year
2-0
brian garcia comes on and gets the final
four outs
notches his first ever four-out save and
the tigers beat cleveland 5-2